Do you feel anxious when Christmas lights start appearing in your neighborhood every year? You're not alone. For some people, the holiday season brings with it not joy and cheer, but stress, loneliness, and sadness. For others, the holidays are a happy time spent reconnecting with family near and far, sharing great meals, engaging, and cherished traditions, but not this year. This strange year, nothing about the holidays will be normal, as many of us will be foregoing family visits, holiday parties, and other traditions. For some people, these changes will be hard to take.
每年当圣诞彩灯开始出现在你的社区时，你会感到焦虑吗？你并不孤单。对一些人来说，节日季带来的不是欢乐和喜悦，而是压力、孤独和悲伤。对另一些人来说，节日是与远近亲友重新联系、分享美食、参与珍贵传统的快乐时光，但今年却并非如此。在这个奇怪的一年里，节日的一切都不会正常，因为我们许多人将放弃家庭聚会、节日派对和其他传统。对一些人来说，这些变化将难以接受。
For others, they might be a welcome relief. I'm talking about the holiday blues. You've probably heard the term, and while there's no formal diagnosis of holiday blues, these feelings are quite real for some people. What exactly are the holiday blues? How might they be different this year? And for those of you who are sad at the thought of a holiday season, unlike any other, what can you do to cope this year?
对另一些人来说，这可能是一种受欢迎的解脱。我指的是“节日忧郁症”。你可能听说过这个词，虽然没有关于节日忧郁症的正式诊断，但这些感觉对某些人来说是非常真实的。到底什么是节日忧郁症？今年它们会有什么不同？对于那些想到一个与众不同的节日季而感到悲伤的人，今年你们能做些什么来应对呢？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. If you enjoy speaking of psychology, the conversation doesn't have to stop when the podcast is over. Get unlimited access to hundreds of videos about the latest in psychology for just one low price by registering for access to APA's 2020 virtual convention. Start with some of our selected videos featuring psychology's biggest names, discussing topics such as COVID-19, racism, and stigma,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。如果你喜欢《心理学谈话》，对话不必在播客结束时停止。注册参加美国心理学会2020年虚拟大会，只需支付一笔低廉的费用，即可无限次观看数百个关于心理学最新进展的视频。从我们精选的一些视频开始，这些视频由心理学界的大腕主讲，讨论诸如COVID-19、种族主义和污名化等话题，
or let your curiosity take the lead and use our on-demand library to explore any topic. Go to convention. .APA.org slash podcast. That's convention. a.org.org slash podcast. My guest today is Dr. Elaine, Rodino, a psychologist in private practice in State College, Pennsylvania. She's an APA fellow and a former president of APA's division of psychologists in independent practice. She's also had a longstanding
或者让你的好奇心引导你，利用我们的点播库探索任何主题。请访问 convention.apa.org/podcast。网址是 convention.apa.org/podcast。我今天的嘉宾是伊莱恩·罗迪诺博士，她是宾夕法尼亚州州立学院的一名私人执业心理学家。她是美国心理学会的研究员，也是美国心理学会独立执业心理学家分会的前任主席。她也有着长期的
interest in the holiday blues and has helped many of her patients with this issue over the years. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Rodino. Thank you. Good to be here. Let's start with a broad definition. What are holiday blues? As I said earlier, there's no actual diagnosis, but is it a real condition and what are its hallmarks? Yes, it is a real condition and I'm really glad you noted that it's not a diagnosable condition. So that it's a condition that usually appears around the holidays and then fades away some time in January. And what are they?
对节日忧郁症的兴趣，多年来帮助了许多患有此问题的患者。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，罗迪诺博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。让我们从一个广泛的定义开始。什么是节日忧郁症？正如我之前所说，没有实际的诊断，但它是一种真实的疾病吗？它的标志是什么？是的，它是一种真实的状况，我很高兴你指出它不是一种可诊断的疾病。所以它通常出现在节日期间，然后在1月份的某个时候消失。它们是什么？
What are these feelings? They could vary. To some people, it's a feeling of malaise. They just feel tired. They can't get to things. Other people, it's the traditional bah humbug attitude. They hate the holidays, can't wait until they're over, that kind of thing. And to some people, they're just stressed out.
这些感觉是什么？它们各不相同。对一些人来说，这是一种不适感。他们只是感到疲倦。他们无法处理事情。对另一些人来说，这是传统的“讨厌鬼”态度。他们讨厌节日，迫不及待地想让节日结束，诸如此类。对一些人来说，他们只是压力过大。
They're like just scattered all over the place and just in a frenzy of needing to do so many things. So, however this affects people, and for some people, they don't have this at all. So it's not that you must have one of these conditions. And, you know, and again, it's good to know that they do fade away in January. How did you first become interested in this topic? Ah, that's an interesting story. This was way back when I was an intern in psychology at the Los Angeles Suicist, suicide prevention center, which since that time has now been taken over by the D.D. Hirsch
他们就像完全分散了注意力，陷入了需要做太多事情的狂热中。所以，无论这如何影响人们，有些人根本没有这种感觉。所以并不是说你必须有这些症状之一。而且，你知道，再次强调，知道它们在1月份消失是件好事。你是怎么开始对这个话题感兴趣的？啊，那是一个有趣的故事。那是在我还在洛杉矶自杀预防中心做心理学实习生的时候，该中心后来被D.D.赫什接管了
Mental Health Center in Los Angeles. Well, the center at that time was the very first suicide prevention center. The leaders there were the ones that created the programs for suicide and suicide hotlines. And media would very actively come and talk with people, interview us. And that's actually how I also started doing work with media and get comfortable working with the media. Well, they would come every holiday time and want to know, is true more people commit suicide in December? And the response is, no, they don't. It's not a higher suicide month. But, But what the gurus at the suicide prevention center started to formulate was and coined the term holiday blues, that there were these feelings of blues, but not a diagnosable depression or suicidalness.
洛杉矶心理健康中心。嗯，当时的那个中心是第一个自杀预防中心。那里的领导者是创建自杀和自杀热线项目的人。媒体会非常积极地来和人们交谈，采访我们。这实际上也是我开始与媒体合作并适应与媒体工作的方式。嗯，他们会在每个节日期间来，想知道：12月自杀的人真的更多吗？回答是，不，他们没有。这不是自杀率最高的月份。但是，自杀预防中心的专家们开始制定并创造了“节日忧郁症”这个词，即存在这些忧郁的感觉，但不是可诊断的抑郁症或自杀倾向。
Why do you think that myth persists that there are more suicides around the holidays? It is, well, I think it's decreased over time because I've been. doing interviews about holiday blues since that time. And I have seen decrease. In fact, I haven't been asked that question in many years. So I think people are now focusing on holiday blues rather than suicide. Or they're reading the statistics and they see that it's not actually there, perhaps. Right. So you've been a practitioner for a long time. And is this something that you see commonly in your practice among your patients? Do you see an uptick in blues during the hospital? holidays? Well, I don't believe I have ever had anyone actually come to therapy because of holiday
你认为为什么关于节日期间自杀人数更多的神话会持续存在？嗯，我认为随着时间的推移它已经减少了，因为我从那时起就一直在做关于节日忧郁症的采访。我已经看到了减少。事实上，我已经很多年没有被问到那个问题了。所以我认为人们现在关注的是节日忧郁症，而不是自杀。或者他们正在阅读统计数据，发现事实并非如此。对。所以你已经做了很长时间的从业者了。这是你在你的患者中常见的情况吗？你在节日期间看到忧郁症的增加吗？嗯，我不相信我曾经有任何人因为节日
blues. But almost all my patients discuss it in their sessions. You know, during the holiday time, there's always conversations about how they're going to get through the holidays, what they're doing, what the stresses are, how they're going to deal with getting together with family. And this year, With the pandemic, it's, you know, totally, you know, another whole layer of issues going on. And by the way, there are fewer issues in some respects because many people are not doing face-to-face gatherings. So there's a reduction in some of the stress that goes on with that. So you're hearing that the people, for example, who are afraid to get together with, you know, Uncle Mori because we don't agree on politics, you're not going to see Uncle Mori. this year. Absolutely. But it still comes up because they're worried about Uncle Maury showing up on
忧郁症而真正来接受治疗。但几乎我所有的患者都会在他们的疗程中讨论它。你知道，在节日期间，总是有关于他们将如何度过节日、他们在做什么、压力是什么、他们将如何处理与家人团聚的对话。而今年，随着疫情的到来，你知道，完全是，你知道，另一层问题正在发生。顺便说一句，在某些方面问题更少了，因为许多人没有进行面对面的聚会。所以这减少了一些随之而来的压力。所以你听到的是，例如，那些害怕与，你知道，莫里叔叔聚在一起的人，因为我们在政治上意见不合，你今年不会见到莫里叔叔。绝对是。但它仍然会出现，因为他们担心莫里叔叔会出现在
Zoom. Don't give him the link. Well, you can always somehow have a technical malfunction and disconnect. Sorry, I can't hear you. Well, who is most at risk of getting holiday blues? Well, I kind of see there can be some what you may think of as bad reasons and you may think of other reasons as good reasons. I find most of the time it's related to issues that happen to people earlier in their lives. and under the bad category, the examples would be having an alcoholic parent, often an alcoholic parent would have a way of just really ruining a holiday. You know, as the drinking goes on during the day,
Zoom上。别给他链接。嗯，你总是可以以某种方式出现技术故障并断开连接。抱歉，我听不见你说话。嗯，谁最容易患上节日忧郁症？嗯，我发现这可能有一些你可能认为是坏的原因，也可能有一些你认为是好的原因。我发现大多数时候它与人们早年生活中发生的问题有关。在坏的类别下，例子包括有一个酗酒的父母，通常酗酒的父母会有一种真正毁掉节日的方式。你知道，随着白天喝酒的继续，
they may become hostile, aggressive, and somehow really make an ugly Christmas day or Thanksgiving Day. or, you know, or, you know, kind of the Uncle Maury's stories that they remember. And that's why those kind of jokes persist because they did happen. There could be some pretty hostile family arguments and people storming out. And, you know, I never heard of food fights. But, you know, and for children, it could be pretty memorable in negative ways. People may feel uncomfortable with holidays without even particularly remembering why,
他们可能会变得敌对、好斗，并以某种方式真正让圣诞节或感恩节变得丑陋。或者，你知道，或者，你知道，有点像他们记得的莫里叔叔的故事。这就是为什么那些笑话会持续存在，因为它们确实发生过。可能会有一些相当敌对的家庭争吵，人们愤然离去。而且，你知道，我从未听说过食物大战。但是，你知道，对于孩子来说，这可能以负面的方式令人难忘。人们可能会对节日感到不舒服，甚至不记得为什么，
but they just are uncomfortable with it. On the good side, some people have early childhood memories of everything being so perfect. They had families, you know, maybe their father decorated the house and it was the best, most lit up house in the whole neighborhood. or, you know, their mother baked 300 cookies and wrap them beautifully and delivered them to all the neighbors. Well, these then get taken on as traditions and people feel they need to do that kind of special over-the-top holiday. And, you know, so that can bring a lot of stress, the expectations of what they feel, either negative or positive. So then for this year, I mean, the people who are. have those good memories, they may not be able to share them. And what's going to happen to those folks?
但他们就是对它感到不舒服。在好的一面，有些人有童年早期的记忆，一切都那么完美。他们有家庭，你知道，也许他们的父亲装饰了房子，那是整个社区里装饰得最好、灯光最亮的房子。或者，你知道，他们的母亲烤了300个饼干，把它们包装得很漂亮，并把它们送到所有的邻居那里。嗯，这些然后被当作传统，人们觉得他们需要做那种特别的、过度的节日。而且，你知道，所以这会带来很大的压力，他们所感受到的期望，无论是负面的还是正面的。那么对于今年，我的意思是，那些有这些美好记忆的人，他们可能无法分享它们。那些人会发生什么？
Well, yeah, well, see, even those good memories become problems because it adds to the stress that they feel that they need to follow in those traditions that their parents did. And I always advise people to start their own traditions, either, you know, as yourself or family. If people always just followed traditions. My favorite thing to say is, if we never changed and evolved, we would still be celebrating the way they did in the medieval times. Things would have never changed. So clearly, people, you know, zig and thag and create new ways of doing things. And this year is, you know, a major change. So people do need to become creative. and think up new ways to celebrate.
嗯，是的，嗯，看，即使是那些美好的记忆也会成为问题，因为它增加了他们的压力，他们觉得他们需要遵循他们父母所做的那些传统。我总是建议人们开始他们自己的传统，无论是，你知道，作为你自己还是家庭。如果人们总是只遵循传统。我最喜欢说的话是，如果我们从不改变和进化，我们仍然会以中世纪的方式庆祝。事情永远不会改变。所以很明显，人们，你知道，曲折前进并创造新的做事方式。而今年是，你知道，一个重大的变化。所以人们确实需要变得有创造力，并想出新的庆祝方式。
You have some strategies or your clients asking you or just discussing what you might do instead? Yeah, you know, what I would also advise is just Googling ideas for pandemic holidays. And in fact, preparing for this interview, I Googled it to see what was there. And there are pages of ideas. So, you know, there's something. for everyone. A survey that we did at APA quite a while ago was actually 2006. It found that women were more likely than men to report higher stress during the holidays.
你有一些策略，或者你的客户在问你，或者只是在讨论你可能会做什么来代替？是的，你知道，我也会建议只是谷歌搜索疫情期间节日的点子。事实上，在准备这次采访时，我谷歌搜索了一下看看有什么。而且有几页的想法。所以，你知道，每个人都有适合的东西。我们在美国心理学会很久以前做过的一项调查，实际上是2006年的。它发现女性比男性更有可能报告在节日期间有更高的压力。
And I think we theorized that a lot of the work of preparing for these celebrations falls on women. Does this ring true for you? Is it your experience that women experience the holiday blues more severely or in greater numbers? I, yeah, and no, I don't, I don't think I can say statistically in greater numbers, but the issues are different. I think the men have more often been concerned about the Uncle Maury situations and the women more worried about the 300 cookies. And that would be the doing more. But the men also would be decorating the house to be. the best of the neighborhood. So for people who are feeling trepidation right now or looking ahead to
我想我们推测，准备这些庆祝活动的大部分工作都落在了女性身上。这对你来说是真的吗？你的经验是女性更严重或更多地经历节日忧郁症吗？我，是的，不，我不认为我能在统计上说数量更多，但问题是不同的。我认为男性更多时候担心的是莫里叔叔的情况，而女性更担心那300个饼干。那将是做更多的事情。但男性也会装饰房子，成为社区里最好的。所以对于现在感到忧虑或展望
November and December, what would you advise people to do in order to cope, particularly if they're feeling stressed already? Well, one thing is realizing that it's time limited. Another is doing self-care things, you know, making sure you keep up with the usual self-care things that you do, you know, whether it's exercising, taking a warm bath, just taking a break and reading a book. So there needs to be just some time that you just check out from the holiday stress part. So wearing your therapist hat, what about people who were having the holiday blues and feel really bad? I mean, how do you know when you're slipping from just basic holiday blues that will go away into something that could be more serious or long-term? Yeah, and I think it is the two things.
11月和12月的人，你会建议人们做什么来应对，特别是如果他们已经感到压力了？嗯，一件事是意识到它是有时限的。另一件事是做自我保健的事情，你知道，确保你跟上你通常做的自我保健的事情，你知道，无论是锻炼、洗个热水澡，还是只是休息一下读本书。所以需要有一些时间，你只是从节日压力的部分中抽离出来。所以戴上你的治疗师帽子，那些患有节日忧郁症并感觉非常糟糕的人怎么办？我的意思是，你怎么知道你何时从只会消失的基本节日忧郁症滑向可能更严重或长期的东西？是的，我认为这是两件事。
One is how dysfunctional is it making you during the holiday time? You know, are you just staying in bed, pulling the covers over your head, just waiting for the calendar pages to slip by? And then the other thing is, how long does it last into January? Usually this starts fading the first couple of weeks in January. So if people are still feeling that by, say, the second, third week of January, then they really should talk with a psychologist because there could be issues that really need to be sorted out and process. Speaking of January, so the blues might go away, but then you've made some New Year's resolutions and maybe by the third or fourth week. You're saying, well, I can't go to the gym and it's really hard to work out at home.
一是它在节日期间让你有多么功能失调？你知道，你只是呆在床上，把被子拉过头顶，只是等着日历页翻过去吗？然后另一件事是，它持续到1月份有多久？通常这在1月份的前几周开始消退。所以如果人们在1月份的第二、第三周仍然有这种感觉，那么他们真的应该和心理学家谈谈，因为可能有一些问题真的需要被理清和处理。说到1月，所以忧郁症可能会消失，但你已经做了一些新年决心，也许到了第三或第四周。你说，嗯，我不能去健身房，在家锻炼真的很难。
And are people beating themselves up because they're not keeping the resolutions? Yeah, that's another whole set of issues, right? The New Year resolutions, that's actually another podcast you can do. Oh, yeah. Because there are tips on making them reasonable and not have this kind of magical thinking that you're going to become this different person on January 1st. Well, I think it would be good maybe to talk a little bit about that now because then people can be prepared, you know, that you start thinking about it in December.
人们是否因为没有遵守决心而自责？是的，那是另一整套问题，对吧？新年决心，那实际上是你可以做的另一个播客。哦，是的。因为有一些关于使它们合理并且不要有这种神奇思维的技巧，即你会在1月1日成为这个不同的人。嗯，我想现在谈谈那个可能很好，因为这样人们就可以做好准备，你知道，你开始在12月考虑它。
Like, you know, the January 1st is coming. So what are realistic ways of preparing for trying to be better, say, in the new year, but not going over the top? Well, exactly the way you said it. I think it is good to think ahead and think, well, it's a new year, fresh start. Hopefully, 2021 will be a better year. And, you know, what do I want to accomplish? What do I want to do?
就像，你知道，1月1日快到了。那么，为尝试变得更好，比如说，在新的一年里，但不要做得过火，有什么现实的准备方式？嗯，完全就像你说的。我认为提前思考并思考，嗯，这是一个新的一年，新的开始。希望2021年将是更好的一年。而且，你知道，我想完成什么？我想做什么？
And have it be reasonable because, you know, as I said before, you are still you. You know, don't think you're suddenly going to be this super human being capable of, you know, these grand things. You're not going to do an Iron Man kind of thing if you don't even take. Iike. And what about you, do you have some coping strategies that you're working on for this year? I think just hoping that we can all get out and socialize again. But in the meanwhile, in terms of coping strategies, I do a lot of video virtual meetings. You know, aside from my practice being totally virtual, I do socialize a lot.
并且让它合理，因为，你知道，正如我之前所说，你仍然是你。你知道，不要认为你突然会成为这个能够，你知道，这些宏伟事情的超人。如果你甚至不走路，你就不会做铁人三项那种事情。那么你呢，你今年有什么正在努力的应对策略吗？我想只是希望我们都能再次出去社交。但与此同时，在应对策略方面，我做了很多视频虚拟会议。你知道，除了我的执业完全是虚拟的之外，我确实做了很多社交。
And I'm so surprised that I almost have to remind myself that I'm not needing people in person. So it's really helpful. Yeah, yeah. So that's a good thing to keep in mind, I think, as we get toward Christmas and you can't go see the grandchildren, but you can zoom with them. Right. That's right. Well, this has been very helpful. I hope that a couple of these tips will make people feel better as we get into the holiday season. so I want to thank you for joining us today, Dr. Rodino.
而且我很惊讶，我几乎不得不提醒自己，我不需要亲自见到人。所以这真的很有帮助。是的，是的。所以我想当我们接近圣诞节时，记住这一点是件好事，你不能去见孙子孙女，但你可以和他们视频通话。对。没错。嗯，这非常有帮助。我希望当我们进入节日季时，其中几个小贴士会让人们感觉更好。所以我想要感谢你今天加入我们，罗迪诺博士。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spokenof Psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening.
谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。